buenas tardes primero de todo decir que
esta estas elecciones se están siguiendo
con sumo interés desde bruselas porque
preocupan enormemente lo que pueda
ocurrir en francia porque también puede
tener un efecto en el resto de países
europeos las propuestas de macrón lo
hemos escuchado en este debate no podían
ser ramas opuestas por una parte en
akrón ha hecho una defensa a ultranza
del eje franco-alemán de la propia
defensa europea es una defensa una
defensa de los valores que de hecho es
lo mismo que defender en bruselas este
refuerzo del proyecto europeo de los
valores europeos la capacidad de que
trabajando juntos todos los países
europeos pueden hacer muchísimo más por
el contrario tenemos la tenemos la
posición de marilé le pen que pone en
duda cuestiones básicas de la
legislación europea y esto es
precisamente lo que preocupa en bruselas
de techo sigan a marine lepén muchas de
las cuestiones que están en su programa
son
un choque directo contra bruselas y
contra la legislación europea como por
ejemplo de las propuestas es que las
personas no puedan acceder a la
seguridad social a la sanidad también
los que tengan uno de los progenitores
franceses esto es una vulneración muy
grave del derecho europeo de los
derechos fundamentales esto podría
provocar por ejemplo aperturas de
expedientes que podrían acabar en la
justicia europea o también una violación
del estado de derecho que podría llevar
a que por lo tanto la comisión europea
podría incluso congelar los fondos
europeos porque tiene varios mecanismos
para evitar que el estado miembro
no viole estos derechos fundamentales
así que una situación así no es de
ningún agrado por parte de bruselas
preocupa mucho hay que tener en cuenta
que francia es un país fundador de la
unión europea
su liderazgo es básico dentro del
proyecto europeo pero si gana marine
lepén podrá ver un gran choque con am
bruselas pero no sólo por las tensiones
también puede provocar enormes
divisiones dentro de la unión europea y
esto podría favorecer sobre todo a una
sola persona que se presenta de rusia
vladimir putin que lo que justamente ha
buscado es esta división dentro de la
unión europea que en estos dos meses se
ha comprobado no lo ha podido conseguir